make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and we are picking back
up again with x of swords this time the
wolverine
story and we're focusing on part three
now here's the thing here's a cool thing
i like about exoswords
this is a throwback to the way that
marvel used to do comics back in the
1990s when they did major crossover
events only this time it's a lot more
organized
uh back in the day a little bit of
history here for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with this
back in the day at least when i started
reading comics and even like before the
1990s they did this
but back in the day you didn't really
have numbered
crossover events in dc comics you had
like you did have that with like
crisis on infinite earth but that was
such a big event that at the time that's
what made it so one of the things that
made it so landmark was like it was
the crisis on infinite events or christ
on infinite story you did have
like crisis on earth one crisis on earth
too uh that really came long before that
right back in the 60s i think but
the cool thing what was interesting is
that back then in the 90s
you would have a crossover event that
would just span a whole bunch of
individual comic book lines right so
imagine now when you have crossovers
except you don't have a main story so
like civil war
if civil war happened over the course of
a bunch of individual character or team
comics and didn't have a core story like
civil war one two
three four all the way up to seven or
however many issues that it was that's
how it was done back then
this is much is done very much the same
way you have what's basically the omega
and the alpha comic which is how they
used to do it back in the 90s right so
like exo swords creation number one is
the equivalent to the 1990s like exo
swords alpha and then when you get to
the very end it'd be like exo-swords
omega the kind of opening issue
and the closing issue right and
everything just kind of falls in between
and i kind of like this right it's an
old throwback
it's it's kind of cool the way that it
used to be but from there
really the way this kind of kicks off is
you basically pick up with wolverine
wolverine basically emerging out of the
pits of hell now how we got
here will be explained over this um it's
not really required that you read the
first five issues of wolverine you can
if you want to but that largely deals
with the blood of wolverine being taken
by vampires and handed over to their
leader dracula so the vampires can walk
around in the day in the night and
that's basically
it omega red has a role in that but it's
by no means the most important thing
ever and if i'm being kind of honest a
little bit lackluster for an opening
wolverine story arc to be quite frank
but this initially kicks off with with
wolverine kind of emerging from here
kind of merging out of the pits of hell
and making this kind of comment about
how you know for a lot of people going
to hell and back
is just an expression but for wolverine
he's done it more than once but the
problem is that you know for from
wolverine's perspective
hell is a place where basically your
past catches up with you and for the
mutant population
the past is catching up with krakowa and
that's where you kind of have wolverine
talking to kakoa itself and basically
saying like at the end of the day like
you're only your voice here is the only
one that really matters but the reality
of this
is that you've been in existence ever
since the creation of
really kind of the splitting of this
home island right and so now you have
morocco and you have
krakowa and the issue with this is that
you wanted that external gate to stay
open because you knew it would
ultimately lead to war right maybe some
kind of reunification but you knew war
would happen
at some point during that process i.e
you wanted war the thing to understand
is i will play my part here i will go
track down the muramasa blade like i'm
supposed to but just know this krakow i
don't trust you and i never will
right i don't see you as a trustworthy
being and so what you end up getting
here is kind of wolverine giving us this
little bit of a flashback right like his
wife itsu the death of itsu the belief
that his son had died as well of course
his son being deacon who didn't die and
kind of went on to
to be raised accordingly with the
reworking of wolverine's origin which i
never completely agreed with but you
also end up having him visiting ken
harada and the reason why is because
wolverine wants to know uh where
muramasa is right like where's muramasa
gone to now the funny thing about
miramasa himself
he's fashioned different weapons and
arms and armament over the course of his
life
and he's been around for hundreds of
years the belief is that muramasa is
immortal but it was never actually
confirmed by marvel comics that he is an
immortal character instead like he's
basically vanished here and the concern
of wolverine is
where his mirror must have gone now the
significance of the muramasa blade is
twofold
the first is the fact that of course
it's one of the swords that has to be
hunted for
and used during this major conflict that
saturnine set in motion but the other
thing that's important here is that the
muramasa blade has the ability to
nullify healing factors the idea is that
you could use the miramasa blade to
basically cut through wolverine and then
to like cut his head off
and then remove like put the two pieces
in two different locations right that
was the xavier protocols to effectively
keep wolverine dead to separate his head
from his body and to never reunify the
two because he cannot
grow back ahead right he would just stay
dead for however long that happens to be
but ken harada is a silver samurai as a
person is probably the best person to
start with because it's silver samurai
right between his knowings about the
comings and goings in japan his
swordsmanship his times with harada
i'm sorry with that with muramasa he's
the person to start with and so
initially ken harad is kind of pissed
because he feels like he should have
been the one to be tasked with tracking
down the muramasa blade of course it
makes sense that it would be wolfrain
right because wolverine was the one who
commissioned the blade to be made in the
first place
that when his wife isu had been killed
that combined with all the experience
that he had gone through before
led to him going to muramasa and saying
i need you to craft a blade for me so
that if i use it i can make god bleed
and
ultimately it took a whole bunch of
years to make this sword but when it was
done
it was a sword that could kill virtually
anybody right there really isn't anybody
out there that can survive being
decapitated by the sword or something
like that now at the end of the day you
end up having wolverine of course who
gets the upper hand on uh on
silver samurai and then says like tell
me what you know and that's when harada
says all i know are rumors now at this
point
we switch over to morocco right to the
tower of what's called broken will
and we're basically following the
horseman war here and what we end up
getting
is that there's a person put inside this
this temple of broken will who's been
here for a hundred years right well it's
a hundred years of the season so however
long a season is down here in in uh in
morocco but basically a hundred years
and that this person was tasked here or
put here because of the fact that this
being had basically killed the husband
of war somewhere along the line and so
we end up finding out that this person
who's here is a guy by the name of
solemn and the hope or the belief was
that in the time that he's been here he
would have lost his mind or he would
have basically gone crazy but
the funny thing about this is solemn is
a sane as ever right he's insane as
he's ever been because while he was
trapped down in this tower that was
designed to break his will
and to drive him insane that people who
were supportive of him have actually
been providing him with gifts and
different things like that
now the motivation for solemn killing
bracken the husband of war
is never fully given to us instead we're
kind of given what are basically a
series of speculations
that people don't really seem to know
that all solemn has is what's basically
kind of like a self-professed agenda
right in the sense that
he he is a person who enjoys
gamesmanship right so he's a lot like
the grand master
from from marvel comics but his loyalty
isn't to anybody but himself
right it's just music flesh and wine and
that's basically it sometimes blood
right
really nothing more than that but the
idea was that bracken who was the
husband of war and the father of
summoner
that the indication is that the ability
of of solemn to kind of seduce other
people
came to bear with his ability to seduce
bracken right so effectively he was
he was you know had dabbled in in being
gay right and being with guys and so the
result of this is that the kind of
speculation comes into play and the
since this believed that the possibility
was there that the whole goal of solemn
was to actually seduce war but it
couldn't be done
and so the result was that solemn
seduced bracken and then killed him in
order to get back at war or maybe that
he had made an advantage a kind of an
advancement towards war and war rebuked
it whatever the case is you know we
don't really know but all we really know
is that for whatever reason
he killed bracken and that kind of led
him to this place the other part of this
is that uh that war had presented him
presented a solemn
with basically the hellblade right the
blade of bracken and the hopes that
having this in his possession and then
losing his mind would lead to him
basically killing himself right and he
would be sent directly to hell but none
of that really seems to have happened
and in fact war is kind of shocked to
the fact that none of it really seemed
to happen
right and so with this with this kind of
going down the way that it was uh you
end up having them basically approaching
solomon saying like the reason why we're
here
is because you have to track down the
muramasa blade right like normally we
would leave you here or we might even
kill you ourself right but the funny
thing about this is that solemn appears
to be an unkillable character but he
seems to be
it seems to be someone that nobody out
there can kill and so the result is that
they end up freeing him and basically
say like
you need to go and find the muramasa
blade right like that's the whole point
that's what you have to do and so solemn
effectively kind of goes on his mission
right he's got three days to do it and
it's like okay
then like let's let's go do this right
and so from there you pick back up with
wolverine kind of jumping a little bit
between the past and the present
some of this and in terms of stuff in
the past it's really designed to kind of
flesh out things that for the most part
if you've been reading wolverine for any
measure of time you already knew but if
you're new to wolverine you wouldn't
really know a lot of that stuff
right but it's basically just this idea
that itsu had been killed and that
wolverine went on a war path trying to
find muramasa in a way to basically
enact his revenge right that he had an
exceedingly violent life he was
basically kind of a killer for hire and
then when he met itsu
that it basically kind of brought him
back and really calmed him down right it
showed him that he could have a life
outside of this violent life that he'd
been living and losing her
kind of solidified this idea to logan
that like he could never actually find
peace
that peace would always elude him for
the rest of his life and so in his anger
and in his vengeance he ended up
tracking down muramasa and and
essentially having muramasa
create a blade for him the other thing
that kind of comes out of this is you
end up having what's called the hand
that when he eventually located muramas
or at least he went to travel back to
see him at some point in time
muramasa had basically been killed in
kind of a ritual sacrifice by the hand
and ultimately sent to what was
basically hell and so in the moment and
the kind of present moment where
wolverine basically emerges from hell
itself
this is basically the journey he went on
right that the rumors that ken harada
had heard were that muramasa had
basically been sent to hell or was
operating in hell
as an agent of the hand and that
wolverine effectively had to travel
there in order to find
muramasa right so that's why he just
kind of wakes up in the pits here but
the hand is an interesting concept in
marvel right and we've talked about them
before
the hand as most of you guys know is
like a mystical ninja clan but there's a
little more to them than that
back in the day in in feudal japan uh
you had uh
you know the the kind of japanese empire
as it existed but what you also had were
farmers and and
and people out there who didn't want to
be part of japanese you know the the
japanese empire and so what they did is
they took to the mountainsides and they
started practicing
different forms of martial arts that
were outside of the approval of the
japanese empire but what you ended up
getting were they were all kind of split
and kind of you know broken and
fractured and so on that you had a guy
named kaganobu yoshioka who basically
brought them all together he unified the
entirety of the hand following that the
group started worshiping what was called
the beast and that led to the hand kind
of adopting a lot of these mystical
abilities and to becoming the super
mystical ninja organization out there
right these are the guys who could kill
you in a locked room and nobody would
know how it happened right
that's what's kind of crazy about these
about these guys and so wolverine
basically emerges
from this pit right emerges from this
pit finally finds muramasa and
muramasa's response is
you have to save me you have to get me
out of here because as in
in essence muramasa is working for the
hand and by extension
is working for a demon right so it's
like wolverine versus
basically like the demon of hell right
which is gonna be kind of nuts but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob corps if you guys
enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and i will catch
you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you